before we go a homeless man was reunited
with his family after almost a
quarter-century thanks to the kindness
of two New Jersey police officers video
shows 61 year old Jose Lopez tearfully
hugging his daughters and grandchildren
last week he lost touch with his family
after he moved to Florida suffered
several strokes and ended up homeless
determined to find them Lopez spent all
the money in his social security account
to travel to New Jersey a transit
officer found him wandering around a
train station and alerted a crisis
officer who contacted dozens of people
just days later Lopez saw his daughters
for the first time in more than 24 years
begging him in heaven
I got my two best girls a girlfriend we
always wish the best we always wish we
had him but we you know we were just
grateful for this man police helped
enroll Lopez in a mental health program
and they hope he will soon find
permanent housing near his family
everybody has a story people thanks to
that crisis workers well not only the
police sir made a lot of calls thank you
both